c'est le paquebot du faubourg de france
à belfort une façade des années 60 est
une enseigne qui perpétue la tradition
des galeries lafayette
depuis plus de 50 ans aujourd'hui le
groupe parisien envisage de céder les
murs pour renflouer sa trésorerie
une stratégie appliquée à 21 autres
magasins dans celui de besançon
sur les 57 que compte la flotte et pour
chaque site après travaux de rénovation
la possibilité pour l'acquéreur de louer
les locaux
un franchisé des galeries lafayette à
belfort l'opportunité est perçu
positivement
j'ai rencontré il ya trois semaines la
directrice d'exploitation des nouvelles
galeries qui m'expliquait que le
commerce à belfort ne marchait pas si
mal puisque le magazine belfort est à
des magasins de france de taille
équivalente qui a les meilleurs
résultats
un projet d'autant mieux ressenti ici qu
il s'accompagnerait de l'ouverture
simultanée de deux grandes enseignes
nationales une réponse rationnelle ou
difficultés du commerce local
un commerçant indépendant charge de tout
lui-même l'immobilier les achats la
vente le marketing est aujourd'hui c'est
devenu tellement complexe que si on je
parle tous ces grands groupes l'un si
ils le prennent cette formule qui est en
train d'être annoncée je pense que ça
peut être une solution gagnante-gagnante
pour chacun des partis parce que chacun
fait son métier
reste à savoir si les trois projets de
reprise annoncée pour le début d'année
seront attentifs au sort des salariés de
belfort et de besançon cent trente
personnes au total sont concernés
mettant la direction que les syndicats
se sont abstenues de tout commentaire à
ce sujet